I need a team of good agents I just have
the slow
horses all right make this quick I got
underlings to bully I'm busy no one in
SL house is busy come on get on with it
a team from MI5 has gone R and Standish
has been
taken what's the plan I need a team of
good agents but I just have the slow
horses tra we looking for X military
there will be a reckoning go
go you can wipe your slate clean okay
was another game being played that will
probably lead me worse off I just can't
see what this one is
yet it's an honor to be selected for
field work shut up got
it
[Applause]
really check CCTV I'd be amazed if you
hadn't missed
something I still have oversight of the
slow
horses lucky
me there are men outside with guns some
backup might be handy well I'm busy okay
thanks I'm sure the situation will
resolve
itself they my fire betrayed us just as
coming their way we have to limit the
collateral damage everyone in that
facility is coming out in a body B you
smiling yeah feel alive don't
you what would you done i' have killed
every one of them if they threaten to
kill you on the other hand I'd buy them
a beer and the bullets find out you
get